bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale nous
sommes à New York pour l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies et notre
invité est le ministre des Affaires
étrangères du Nigéria Geoffrey
osnyama et avec moi pour vous
interviewer Christophe Boisbouvier de
RFI monsieur le ministre bonjour
alors cette assemblée générale de l'ONU
s'ouvre dans un climat tendu assombri
même par la guerre en Ukraine alors le
Nigéria avait voté en faveur d'une
résolution au tout début du conflit qui
condamnait l'agression russe mais on
voit que l'agression russe par un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité semble
réellement mettre en danger la raison
d'être de l'ONU est-ce que vous craignez
vraiment pour l'avenir du système
onusien
oui c'est ça a été j'en crois pas que
c'est cette crise de l'Ukraine qui
vraiment mettre en cause toute le
système de Nations Unies et je crois que
pendant il y a d'autres raisons il y a
par exemple pour les pays africains il y
avait un besoin de d'avoir des réformes
de Nations Unies parce que la Nation
Unies c'est une organisation qui qui a
été créé après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et
ce n'est pas aussi inclusive déjà et
parce qu'on sait que c'est les gagnants
de cette guerre qui ont constitué le
Conseil de sécurité et puis la plupart
des pays membres de Nations Unies
n'étaient pas là quand ça a été créé
donc déjà il y a au fond c'est
prospect de cette organisation qui est
vraiment
correspond plus à la
réalité de notre
jour maintenant tant que c'est pas
uniquement les crises en Ukraine qui
mettent cette organisation la raison
d'être de cette organisation cause alors
cette guerre en Ukraine risque de
provoquer une grave crise alimentaire en
Afrique notamment à cause de la pénurie
des engrais des fertilisants russes
Vladimir Poutine dit que c'est à cause
des sanctions
occidentales et les Occidentaux
répliques que c'est faux c'est de la
propagande russe qui a raison dans ce
débat dans cette polémique je crois que
l'essentiel c'est que la président la
secrétaire général des Nations unies
ainsi que le président
Edogan
Turquie
on peut trouver une solution
pour cette crise donc nous allons dans
le bon sens en ce qui concerne la
nourriture alors je vais en venir à
l'Afrique de l'Ouest la CEDEAO avait
pris des sanctions lourdes contre le
Mali en janvier en raison du refus de la
junte de produire un chronogramme
acceptable puis en juillet elle a levé
ses sanctions et à peine quelques jours
plus tard le Mali arrête 49 soldats
ivoiriens les accuses d'être des
mercenaires ce que la Côte d'Ivoire et
les Nations Unies ni donc se pose la
question est-ce que la CDAO n'a pas été
trop vite en levant ses sanctions contre
le Mali en raison de ce qui s'est passé
ensuite
non c'est les deux choses différentes
ils ont enlevé les sanctions parce que
le CDAO
a vu le progrès que les gens te
faisaient
pour
le reconstitution de
d'une
gouvernement démocratique et tout cela
mais la question de ces sodas Ivoriens
c'est toute une autre chose et
donc les dunes sont pas à forcement
liées mais certainement le CEDEAO
à fortement demandé
la libération de ces soldats et moi je
suis porteur de d'une comme on voit
spéciale d'un message le président
Bouhari ensuite à une demande
CEDEAO j'étais là-bas
au Mali j'ai rencontré
le président de la transition et nous
avions faire un moment demandé la
libération de ces 46
soldats sont préconditions et puis
donc comme j'ai dit les deux choses ne
sont pas forcément liés mais
nous n'aimerons pas non plus que
maintenant qu'il y a
que si il persiste il n'y a pas la
libération de ces soldats
ça peut maintenant aggraver la situation
alors justement à l'issue de l'audience
que le colonel assimigoïta vous a
accordé à Bamako il a fait monter les
enchères et il a demandé en contrepartie
l'extradition de trois opposants maliens
actuellement en Côte d'Ivoire
ça a dû évidemment vous surprendre
pourquoi les discussions avec le numéro
1 malien sont-elles si difficiles
difficile
je ne sais pas mais
certainement nous estimons pas non plus
que les deux situations sont liées que
une demande pour l'extradition de des
opposants en Côte d'Ivoire
doivent être
le prix pour la libération de 46
soda à notre avis donc ok maintenant sur
la table il y a cette ligne qui a été
qui a été fait mais
nous espérons vraiment que comme nous
avions demandé
aux autorités
maliens que que qu'il n'y a pas cette
mélange de des choses alors la Côte
d'Ivoire
son président espéré une solution de
négocier il voit que ça traîne donc il
tape du point sur la table il a demandé
qu'un sommet extraordinaire de la CEDEAO
se tienne ici à New York en main de
l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU pour que
la région se libère réclame la
libération de ces soldats donc il y
aura-t-il déjà ce sommet et est-ce que
c'est ça qui va être demandé oui il faut
voir en sépare encore ce qui sera sur
l'eau de jeu pour bien sommeil ici
il y aura un sommet parce que oui c'est
pas le premier souvent le CEDEAO profite
de fait que
ces chefs d'États qui sont à New York en
même temps et profiter de
rassembler pour
débattre quelques
des des choses qui concernent le CEDEAO
mais mais si on cette question il faut
dire
[Musique]
il n'y a pas vraiment l'évidence que
c'est sodas étaient des mercenaires
c'était clair plus ou moins que
il venait dans le cadre de
des forces
ministre mais
c'est vrai aussi
selon après les enquêtes que peut-être
il y avait des aspects
techniques
qui n'était pas vraiment ce que ça
devrait être la jante n'a pas totalement
tort quand elle dit qu'il n'était pas là
selon les règles à suivre
apparemment apparemment
il semble en effet que oui il y avait
cette rythmée qui n'ont pas été suivies
d'après ce que certains comme les
Nations Unies d'ailleurs on dit mais
mais mais
ils n'ont jamais dit Nations Unies que
c'était les mercenaires qui avait des
choses qui qui prouvaient que c'était
des mercenaires donc mais dont vous avez
dit il y avait cette règle qui peut-être
n'a pas été suivi comme comme il fallait
et à ce sommet extraordinaire de la
CEDEAO est-ce que vous envisagez de
nouvelles sanctions si jamais c'est 46
soldats ne sont pas libérés
comme j'ai dit c'est pas sûr exactement
lors du jour de ce sommet
ceux qui vont être discutés mais
là il faut voir ce qui va être discuté
et puis aussi quelle position les
différents chefs d'État
vont prendre sur ces questions vous-même
en tant que ministre des Affaires
étrangères du Nigéria qu'est-ce que vous
préconiserez
vous avez comme je vous ai dit j'étais
une envoie spécial du président Bouhari
sur ces questions
j'avais eu le nom l'honneur d'être reçu
par le président de Mali et j'ai été
envoyé comme on voit spécial de c'est le
président Bouhari parce que pour nous
c'était quelque chose très très
important et déjà notre sous régent
soumis de plusieurs défis
terroristes et aux autres et on ne veut
pas à tout prix ajouter maintenant le
conflit entre des pays de ce sous région
c'est c'est vraiment
scénario que on peut pas accepter donc
c'est pourquoi on a décidé le président
a décidé d'envoyer cette message et donc
certainement
c'est quelque chose très important pour
nous tous dans la CEDEAO de
ne pas laisser les choses aller plus
loin que maintenant donc on va tout
faire pour pour
empêcher que que ça ça devient
un vrai conflit entre deux pays membres
de CEDEAO merci monsieur le ministre de
nous avoir accordé cet entretien et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi sur nos
deux chaînes France 24 et Radio France
Internationale
[Musique]